for nearly 20 years Keithley has been a
marginal seat it currently favors the
conservatives but only just the average
wage here is around 28 000 pounds a year
far from The Loft the incomes of the
wealthy whose High rate of tax was cut
by the chancellor this week while the
conservatives have been criticized for a
policy which appears to favor the rich
rather than those on low-income labor
are desperate to seize on this in order
to win back places like this and the
labor leader Sakia starmer is leading
that March
runs an electrical store in the town and
is not happy with the Tory tax cuts plan
it makes me feel are done by because the
working class
that attack make ends meet are just
worse off
than before and does that open the door
for the labor party and Kia stalma yeah
if I were to vote today I would probably
go labor as a fresh start
says he believes labor is ready to win
the next election so what do people here
think about him and his chances would
you vote for him oh I don't know do you
know much about him not much do you know
what he stands for
no not really do you know what his big
policies are nope
probably just another name another first
another politician it doesn't stand out
to me more than anybody else really
Adrian Chapman who owns the wishbone
Brewery doesn't buy into the idea that
going easy on the rich trickles down to
those who drink his beer and that could
affect how he votes I think that the
entire conservative party could do
better
and does that feeling that they could do
better open the door do you think for
labor to to capitalize on that and what
do you think about their leader
I mean what does he say to you kirstown
is a little bit kind of like middle of
the road type thing and he kind of needs
to be quite forthright and upfront with
people I mean honesty goes a long way so
I've been really really honest with like
voters
the question is whether kierstama and
more broadly labor can tap into those
voters who are looking for a change now
to persuade them that labor might just
be electable again Nick Martin Sky News
Keithley